je crois qu'il est plus par là ouais
c'est ça
et le tien il est plus derrière ou plus
devant
dernière mise en place avant la
répétition générale pour Fanny cette
comédienne plaisiroise de 28 ans a
intégrer le théâtre Eurydice en janvier
2019 cet établissement et service d'aide
par le travail basé à plaisir en gage
des comédiens en situation de handicap
depuis 1986 un travail rémunéré attend
plein pour cette troupe de 9 comédiens
on a beaucoup de chance du coup parce
que tous les artistes ne peuvent pas se
vanter d'avoir un spectacle permanent
comme ça la plupart sont intermittents
et doivent chercher encore et encore
donc je pense qu'on a beaucoup de bol
fanny a commencé le théâtre à l'âge de 6
ans lors d'une représentation d'une
pièce de William Shakespeare en classe
de CP sa mère était fascinée par ses
capacités de mémorisation elle a obtenu
une licence d'études théâtrale à la
Sorbonne Nouvelle allez allez cultiver
allez
à un niveau intellectuel en ordre
très agréable de travailler avec elle je
fais ça pour pouvoir m'amuser tous les
jours et honnêtement je ris tous les
jours donc je pense que je vais avoir
une bonne santé grâce à ça la troupe
repecte actuellement le spectacle
heureusement que vous êtes là mise en
scène par Cécile tournesol et écrit par
Roland Dubillard acrobate du verbe et
jongleur de mots se retrouvent sous un
chapiteau de fin du monde échange entre
ces deux clowns très bavards
pour une fois que je gagne Fanny elle
est très impressionnante elle a des
capacités incroyables de de mémoire ce
qui est surtout aussi
formidable c'est qu'elle a une passion
pour le théâtre et donc voilà on sent
qu'elle est heureuse sur scène je
ressens tout mon corps je ressens tout
ce qu'il y a autour de moi je ressens le
public et il y a quelque chose où quand
je suis sur scène je me sens vivante la
troupe actuellement 3 spectacles et la
pièce heureusement que vous êtes là sur
un représenté les 16 et 17 décembre au
Théâtre Eurydice de plaisir